hello everybody happy Monday morning 9
o'clock here in the East Coast it is
time to continue the gratitude journal
livestream series you guys voted to keep
it around and I'm super excited so this
is gratitude live stream number six and
the reason for doing this I mean look a
little different I'm still getting used
to myself here got the haircut got the
beard all shaved off nice and clean
convert the last week the reason for
this is is happiness is
I don't think entrepreneurs are grateful
enough for the things that they have in
their life and it's super hard to be
angry and upset when you have gratitude
in your heart at the same time and so
this is an exercise day with my team
it's important that you do it every day
this isn't just feel grateful once this
is a muscle that needs to be worked
constantly and I found that it really
helps me through hard times remembering
what I do have and what I should be
grateful for and that maybe the problems
I'm facing aren't that big compared to
other people and that helps we get
through I helps me stay happy
the other key part of it is that you
actually really feel it every day not
just listing 3 things down but actually
feel it feel it in your heart feel
touched by it feel moved by it because
that's when you actually feel gratitude
instead of saying I'm glad I'm grateful
for my wife and Howard Schultz in my
computer like that's mailing it in
that's not real gratitude and so what I
could you guys to do is for those you
watching live put three things in the
chat that you're grateful for for those
you're watching the repeat version leave
it in the comments below then I'm gonna
read some out but first and get to mine
three things that I'm grateful for today
on a Monday morning I'm grateful for my
security team here at this condo
building I've I used to live in this
building a couple little years ago
number years ago I remember how long ago
and the security team was was pretty
good and then kind of fell off but I
wasn't a big fan didn't have a
connection with a lot of the guys there
and I really like the team now haha I
really like the guys as
great to walk in and see them in smiles
on their faces and some of them watch my
videos and it makes a difference when
you walk in the building you know then
and there they're great people and not
just doing their job but they're great
people to hang around too so I'm really
grateful for the whole security and
front desk staff at my buildings I'm I'm
grateful for my parents love I've been
watching Tony Robbins
video I am NOT your guru and I saw any
of you he did with Tim Ferriss
afterwards and one of the things that
Tony Robbins always asked people it's a
big question to ask people who are going
through a difficult time is whose love
did you need more growing up your mom's
and your dad's and not who did you love
more but whose love did you crave more
and then based on that so say you said
okay my dad based on that he would ask
you okay who do you who did you have to
be for your dad to love you and then
typically that's at the core of whatever
is the problem with you we're on
whatever issue you're face right now it
stems from there and I look at back on
my own life and I realized I didn't
really crave either of my parents love
to an unhealthy obsession and I didn't
have to be anybody for them I always
felt loved like no matter what I did I
felt loved and all my crazy ideas when I
was young and being parented they always
supported me and I think that's really
it's if I you know when I do think with
toning I'm asking about it because I
feel like it's maybe abnormal and it may
be why I can go off and have the
confidence to do whatever I want to do
because I always felt loved and that I
don't need extra love but I'll need your
approval to go off and do something I'm
just gonna go out and do it I'm still
thinking about that really makes me
grateful for my parents and that I
didn't have to be anybody but myself and
the three of us like to sip two sisters
all chose totally different paths none
of us are doing the same thing your
parents are doing and that's probably
their
clearly to my parents being so
supportive and loving regardless of what
we're doing so I'm grateful for them and
third I'm grateful for I'm grateful for
my wife Nina's bravery where she wants
to go and try new things and we're at
the beach it was the last weekend in the
summer and so we went to the beach here
in Toronto and we're just walking
randomly and she says I think I'd die in
my hair I want to dye my hair what color
should I dye my hair
and she's talking about the purple like
a dark purple which is which is excited
interesting but a lot of people once
they hit you know their 30s there they
settle in you know they stop taking
risks not that that's a huge risk darn
your hair but you start playing the safe
game you start being boring and for some
people happens even earlier where when
you're young you feel a lot more
confident to do things that are outside
the box and so I'm grateful that that
Nina has she still has her courage and
wants to go and try new things different
things even if it's something as little
as dyeing your hair so I'm excited to
see it I think purple would look sexy
some curious to see how it turns out so
we've got four minutes left and I want
to recognize some of y'all in the chat
and see what you're grateful for
Jairaj people for finding the link
through this this grateful for finding
the link for this on time yes that's
actually my bad I've instructed my
assistant to make these links public
prior so this was a private link and it
went public like two minutes before I
launched so the easy future one should
be easier
Antoine took we're know good morning
everyone
we should come good morning everyone
everybody's everybody's saying hi good
morning that's awesome David a creep
look at my family junior I escaped
before the abundant cash flow throwing
are flowing through our massive economy
I love it I love it J Roz is taking it
to a whole new scale there is a no good
to see you're continuing this Evan I
love it what else grateful for
improving Internet bandwidth fiber and
digital infrastructure grateful for my
girlfriend who keeps pushing me every
time I'm feeling down and overwhelmed
that's a special girl Antoine you got a
let's let's do something to support her
do something today to say thank you
something it's even something small
just something just showing up doesn't
have to be doesn't have to cost money it
doesn't have to be going out and taking
out the dinner or buying flowers or
those are nice but even just sending a
note you know letting her know letting
her know that you told believe nation
how great she was what else motor review
Australia family friends and life
Dylan Perez I'm grateful for my family
and our house Jude grateful for my
health that allows me to work out move
around and have fun I love it Rishi Cup
TV my co-host in three minutes on the
League of Legends business cue a stream
I'm grateful for the ability to hashtag
believe that anything is possible I love
it and and what I love seeing here guys
I know we've talked about it before but
the mix the mix of the big and the small
right the mix of the the big of the
health and the family and relationships
but also the small you know I'm grateful
for you know the coffee Alex brought me
this morning right just a just a small
thing but this it's good to mix them up
to not only focus on the big heavy ones
greet them for opportunities Ravi it's
6:30 to p.m. here I love it Ravi I don't
know where you're based but that's
awesome
thank you for tuning in listen it's also
never too late for gratitude like I'm
starting this at 9:00 in the morning for
everybody in North America we're looking
at 6:00 to 9:00 a.m. start your day but
nothing wrong with 6:00 p.m. doing a
little bit of gratitude check-in as well
to uh you know have a great rest of the
night to Adrienne week full to see let's
continue
I appreciate that Adrienne I'm grateful
for coffee early morning inspirations
and weekends with my kids I love it I'm
curious what your early morning
inspiration is is this it of the the
interesting series is something else
Rishi lots of gratitude lots of
gratitude this morning I love it CW
Spartan I'm grateful for my close
friends family and my education love it
grateful for nourishing delicious food
eggs bacon salad and the metabolism and
well-being to enjoy I feel like bacon
should be a constant baking should
always be something that you're grateful
for Dina
my family my country and youtube.com/
I loved Edina pre Anya I'm grateful that
I found that guys like you
thank you prion a-that's that's awesome
and me I'm super beautiful for all the
comments you guys leave and and keep me
going they know I gave you for being
able to play basketball again without
having to think about my knee
I played 40 minutes a full game
yesterday we got killed but I'm just so
happy to play again I love that Z no I
love it
I didn't get the body part of the day
although I guess the knee is there Xena
was on like a streak of body parts of
the day that's it guys we're at time
it's 9:10 at least for me here we're not
gonna hop on the League of Legends
business QA if you want to hit - my
twitch channel answer there ask some
business questions I'm gonna be there
for those you continue on your day have
an amazing day for those of you watching
after again remember to leave the three
things that you're grateful for
it's a amazing start to the day it makes
you feel refreshed and whole and I will
see you again tomorrow morning continue
to believe or whatever you're one where
it is unless you soon